wo ist ein weg
[Musik]
die serie ist abgedreht
nico glückwunsch und was ist das
das ist eine filmklappe ich habe sie von
meinem chef geschenkt bekommen
das thema doch der klub unterschrieben
beleuchter schauspieler aufnahmeleiter
tun sogar der regisseur
das ist wirklich mal ein cooles
abschiedsgeschenk als ich mal fahrer an
einer filmproduktion war habe ich etwas
nicht bekommen vielleicht warst du
einfach nicht gut genug und alle waren
froh als du wieder weg warst
danke dass sie heute den abwasch macht
ich habe sogar einander szene
mitgespielt
es war nur eine kleine rolle aber es hat
riesen spaß gemacht und ich habe es ja
viel talent nico a
es war das ende einer verfolgungsjagd
der kommissar so schöpft und rennt in
einen fußgänger ich bin der fußgänger
hast du text ja passen sie doch auf dann
helfe ich dem kommissar wieder auf die
beine er rennt weiter und erwünscht am
ende den gangster dank meiner hilfe
was soll ich damit machen ich bin ein
autogramm bevor die berühmte ist
[Gelächter]